GITHUB:
Have you ever wondered were all of the code
for your favorite websites and apps are stored?
Maybe on some sort of network of secret databases
and servers that are guarded by 7 layers of
encryption and firewalls and more security
than the Pentagon?
Well, at one point in time, that was probably
the case but nowadays, everything is on the
cloud as engineers should be able to access
the codebase from anywhere in the world at
any time.
Hearing this, you’re probably inclined to
think that all of the world’s code is stored
on AWS or maybe Azure given the title of the
video.
And you wouldn’t be wrong.
Technically, it is stored on Azure but it’s
not because of Microsoft, it’s actually
thanks to one of their subsidiaries called
GitHub which they paid $7.5 billion for.
GitHub is home to the code repos of Airbnb,
Shopify, Netflix, Robinhood, Reddit, DoorDash,
Walmart, and 90% of the Fortune 100.
This translates to control over 100 million
developers, 4 million organizations, and 330
million repositories.
Essentially, if you were able to hack into
GitHub’s servers, you would get access to
the entire world’s code whether it’s financials,
social media, games, ai, you name it.
As GitHub likes to claim, “This is where
the world builds software” and now, it’s
all controlled by Microsoft.
But how did one company end up getting so
much power over.
Well, it wasn’t always like this.
GitHub isn’t some sort of legacy tech company
founded in the 80s and 90s.
GitHub was only founded 15 years ago in 2008
and it started off as just a regular old bootstrapped
startup funded by four ambitious engineers.
Yet somehow, they’ve been able to convince
the entire world to jump on board, but is
this actually safe and responsible?
I mean, we’re essentially risking the entire
tech world and really much of the world economy
on Microsoft’s security measures.
Well, join me as take a look back at how Microsoft
came to control the entire world’s code
and explore whether this is actually in the
world’s best interest or just Microsoft’s
best interest.
GIT:
Speaking of Microsoft’s domination, with
over $100 billion in cash and liquid investments,
Microsoft wipes the floor with other Fortune
500 companies when it comes to cash reserves.
Most of these liquid investments are actually
in corporate and treasury bonds.
As rates rose over the past year, Microsoft
leaned into bonds and locked in high yields
from the government and other top corporations.
But, it’s not just Microsoft who should
get to capitalize on today's high rate environment.
Through our upcoming bond investing platform,
Silo, retail investors will also get access
to the same institutional grade fixed income
opportunities as massive corporations like
Microsoft.
Silo’s mobile app allows you to build a
customized bond portfolio tailored to your
risk tolerance and income needs.
So while Microsoft profits from higher rates,
you can too by investing in bonds through
Silo.
If that sounds interesting, please consider
joining our waitlist in the link below!
But anyway, to understand how Microsoft came
to dominate this world, we first have to understand
how code used to be stored and distributed
before the 2000s because it was really bad.
I mean just think about it.
When you have thousands of coders who are
working on the same codebase and making millions
of edits to add new features and fix bugs,
you’re naturally gonna run into a lot of
issues.
Joe’s bug revisions are gonna end up breaking
Bob’s new feature.
John’s new efficient algorithm might’ve
forgotten a critical edge case for Mary’s
legacy functionality and so on and so forth.
The bottomline is that getting code from thousands
of engineers to work together in unison is
a very difficult task in itself, and for the
longest time, the solution for this issue
was simply brute force.
Every tech company would have their own databases,
servers, and revision control systems, and
dozens of code librarians and senior engineers
would be hired to simply maintain a healthy
codebase.
These guys wouldn’t write their own code
or algorithms or any of that.
Instead, their full time job was to review
each and every change to ensure that none
of them would break any existing feature or
conflict with parallel changes.
Honestly, this seems like a pretty tedious
and annoying job but it was also very much
critical and necessary until a young man named
Linus Torvalds decided to step in.
Just kidding, Linus didn’t care about this
internal software engineering issue.
He was looking to fry much bigger fish and
compete directly with Microsoft.
If you haven’t figured it out yet, Linus
was the creator of Linux and that’s where
he spent the first 15 years of his professional
life.
But eventually after Linux grew to be much
bigger than just himself, he would turn his
attention to one his biggest frustrations
of software engineering: version control.
Linus was aware of this issue more than anyone
else as he was the head of the biggest open
source project of all time.
At least with companies, you can be sure that
every engineer is skilled and has the companies
best interest in mind atleast to some degree
because well they’re getting paid.
With open source software on the other hand,
literally anyone can contribute so it was
up to people like Linus to ensure that only
the positive changes made their way onto the
repo.
This was always a pain in the butt for Linus
but he put up with it as he was more focused
on the bigger picture.
But, on one fateful night in 2005 when working
on the Linux Kernel, he would reach his wits
end with crappy version control.
He vowed right then and there that he was
gonna solve this issue once and for all.
And with that, he would go offline for 2 weeks,
create a new revolutionary version control
system from scratch, and call it Git.
Honestly, it’s pretty funny to think that
one of the biggest shortfalls within the software
engineering industry could’ve been solved
or atleast largely improved with just 2 week
of focused work.
But for some reason, no one had decided to
take on this project for decades.
Talk about procrastination.
Linus would of course turn around and implement
Git into Linux’s repo which immediately
gave Git a strong reputation within the open
source community.
But, there was still a long way to go in terms
of making Git mainstream.
GITHUB:
You’re probably wondering, what in the world
did Linus do within just 2 weeks that was
so revolutionary?
Well, he largely reduced the work of code
librarians aka, the gatekeepers.
Before Git, engineers were directly working
on the central codebase and this is why having
highly qualified gatekeepers was so important.
These gatekeepers were in charge of making
sure that only high quality code made its
way onto the repo but this also meant that
engineers were spending a lot of their time
just waiting on gatekeepers instead of writing
code.
Ironically, this is still the case at most
big tech companies but for different reasons
like bureaucracy and varying priorities.
Back in the day, the issue was mainly due
to a lack of good coding infrastructure.
Git, however, largely solved this.
Instead of having coders work directly on
the central repository, Git allowed coders
to work on a local version of the repo.
This meant that coders could test any change
they wanted locally without the oversight
of gatekeepers or jeopardizing the central
repo.
As such, coders were able to better troubleshoot
and validate their code before they ever sent
it to the gatekeepers to verify and merge
with the central repo.
This was a revolutionary development but Git
was by no means perfect.
For starters, there was no frontend to Git.
Everything was handled through the terminal
making it difficult to visualize the history
of changes and modifications to a given repo.
Moreover, sharing code between engineers still
wasn’t all that streamlined or polished,
and this is where 4 engineers named Tom Preston
Werner, Chris Wanstrath, PJ Hyett, and Scott
Chacon would step in.
In 2008, these 4 would get to work on putting
a face to Git making it easier than ever to
share, fork, modify, push, and merge code.
For the first time, every developer on a project
could easily view the entire code history,
identify who made what changes, figure out
where things went wrong, and fix conflicts
and production issues with ease.
If a lot of those terms went over your head,
they basically created an insane code management
platform based on Git and they called it Logical
Awesome LLC which is surprisingly similar
to the name of this channel.
Unfortunately though, that name didn’t stick
and they would end up calling it GitHub.
Almost immediately, GitHub was a success on
its own.
It didn’t need any venture capital or funding
or loans or any of that.
In fact, the founders were able to manage
all of the expenses of Git by themselves for
the first 4 years.
After all, it’s not that expensive to store
and distribute a bunch of text.
One of the first companies to embrace Git
was none other than Google in 2008.
This was during the peak of their obsession
with opensource software like Android and
Chromium.
The knew that if they really wanted to appeal
to the opensource community, they needed to
use the same tools which in this case was
Git.
Google would eventually move away from Git
to their own version controlling tool called
Piper but that doesn't really matter because
Google had already put Git and as a result
Github on the mainstream radar.
By 2010, Github was hosting 1 million repos,
and by 2013, they were hosting 10 million
repos.
Most tech companies were just happy to finally
have a modern code management platform but
some wanted a piece of the pie.
This of course included VCs who poured hundreds
of millions into GitHub but it also included
Microsoft.
MICROSOFT TAKES CONTROL:
Microsoft didn’t just go straight for the
acquisiton.
Instead, they started off as just a regular
old GitHub user and supporter.
Starting in 2012, they would move all of their
open source projects, dev tools, and most
of their documentation onto GitHub.
This did wonders for GitHub.
It’s one thing to support a platform.
It’s another to put much of your own code
on that platform, and at this point, both
Google and Microsoft had taken the plunge.
Let’s just say, it was just a matter of
time until everyone else followed suit.
Microsoft watched all of this playout from
the sidelines for several years before finally
making their move in 2018.
The offer was $7.5 billion for the entire
company and frankly this was a deal that the
founders couldn’t turn down as it would
make them billionaires.
But, with that being said, the deal wasn’t
really hostile.
You see, Microsoft wasn’t trying to takeover
and impose their control over the company.
All they really wanted was a star investment
and cloud partner and that’s exactly how
they’ve treated it.
If you don’t believe me, just take it from
GitHub’s CEO himself.
“Microsoft has not forgotten why we did
the deal in the first place and what the important
pillars of the deal are.
The first and foremost principle is to put
developers first.
And that is what we do every day.”
That’s a far cry from how the founders of
Instagram and WhatsApp feel about Zuckerberg
but that’s a wholenother story.
Anyway, as you can see, things have worked
out great for both GitHub and Microsoft but
what about everyone else?
Is it healthy and safe for one company to
have so much power?
Well, if the question is healthy, the answer
is absolutely not.
It is not healthy for one company to control
the codebase of 90% of the fortune 100.
They absolutely need competition and maybe
even regulators but that’ll likely never
happen because GitHub is a background company
that most people don’t even know or care
about.
So, as long as they continue lurking in the
background, they shouldn’t have many issues
with regulators.
But while this system is definitely not healthy,
it is safe.
Given GitHub’s business, they’re naturally
a target for hackers.
A few years ago for example, they were subject
to the largest DDoS attack ever recorded.
But we don’t really have to worry about
this because GitHub’s customers know what
they’re doing.
Here’s the thing, 99% of the code in the
world doesn’t matter, not in the sense that
it’s not important but in the sense that
it’s not proprietary.
Many of the largest projects in the world
like Chrome and Android are already opensource.
And even for the projects that aren’t opensource,
the code base doesn’t really matter.
Just because you have Netflix or YouTube or
Reddit’s codebase doesn't mean that you’ll
even have a chance at competing against them.
For most tech companies, their secret sauce
is their user base, their marketing, their
partnerships, their brand presence, and so
on.
There’s really nothing proprietary about
making API calls or storing data or handling
errors which is what the vast majority of
the world’s code does.
So, companies aren’t exactly worried about
their codebases getting leaked though they
would of course prefer to not go down that
road.
There are very few projects and companies
that actually deal with proprietary code where
the code truly is the hero.
And you can bet that these projects are not
stored on GitHub.
They’re stored on secret databases with
insane levels of security like in the good
old days.
But aside from these few exceptions, virtually
everything is stored on GitHub and that’s
how Microsoft secretly controls every app
in the entire world.
If you’d like to take advantage of high
interest rates and have the government and
top companies pay you 4-7%, check out our
upcoming bond investing app Silo in the description
below.